another edition of mom texts yes all  right as many as you know my mom's  Liberal Democrat and sends me texts  during the show to to critique me here  we go  what makes you think it's appropriate to  viciously disparage insult and dismiss a  member of Congress how does that  behavior contribute to any sort of civil  discourse humility helps character  counts think about that yes next one oh  my goodness and you actually believe  Trump is not divisive you've been  swallowed by semantic quicksand please  pronounce your ings the word is pudding  pecan restocking and then my favorite I  am honestly concerned that your  colleagues have begun to roll their eyes  and the last one I cannot watch today or  tomorrow so bring back the kind Jessie  [Music]  [Applause]  please prinos great